[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited and grateful to be talking
about peace and justice activism we have
Jody Evans joining us on the show hello
how that was things done thank you so
much for coming on really appreciate it
and we're really excited to talk to Jody
Jody has a massive background in peace
and justice activism she is the
co-founder of code pink she has been
doing this how many years now two
decades activism I've been doing for 47
years
okay forty-four and a half four four and
a half decades of activism yeah that's
crazy
code blue pink or in our 16th year 16th
year but we didn't ever want to start an
organization
I mean code pink was a response to
Bush's lies that were you know taking us
to war and he used the terrorist codes
red orange and yellow to frighten the
American people so we called code pink
for peace clearly knowing that the idea
of going to war in Iraq was so stupid it
would never happen and so we tried to
stop that war we had to continue because
threats of more Wars continued and now
we're in six we've got three hotspots
and the work continues the work does
continue there's a massive war economy
there's a massive military industrial
complex there's a massive amount of
humans that we've raised as seeds
without the proper nutrients and water
of this it since yourself work in this
inner development oh no no we've
literally raised them on militarism I
mean that's the seeds that have been
planted
they had seeds they just weren't seeds
apiece
and across the world yeah well you know
I'm just a day out of Iran so there are
places in the world that are not raised
on militarism that are raised on love
and the value of peace so yeah that is
true and I want to say that I last night
walking around in your neighborhood at
10:30 at night I cried for about 25
minutes coming from Iran a place of
generosity and caring and a real deep
understanding of peace you know one that
probably came out of having a war what
killed a million people but to walk the
streets of the Tenderloin of San
Francisco and see the number of people
thrown away em was really disturbing and
massive war economy so you know after
being in code pink and all the work we
were doing to end war I realized we're
not gonna end war until we end the war
economy because Wars just serving the
war economy and it's doing a very good
job of it so trying to be an anti-war
activist while we live inside a war
economy which is basically our culture
is a tough scene so I looked at it like
okay so there's this war economy which
is killing us our communities and the
planet and if we look at that
mythologically because every you know
culture has like the spud flood
mythology so say it was our flood what
would the Ark be that we would build and
out of that came growing a local peace
economy peace economy because the war
economy is the extractive destructive
you know oppressive economy but there's
this other economy it's the giving
sharing caring thriving relational
resilient economy without which none of
us would be alive but we all think we
get life from the war economy we all I
give all of ourselves to this war
economy when literally we are alive
because of the peace economy because of
the way we take care of each other how
we're parented you know the things that
really nurture life
are the things in the peace economy but
we've been seduced to thinking it's the
southern economy and we give our time
and our money and our effort and we play
the game of the war economy which
thrives on alienation and separation and
making us believe that we live in
scarcity instead of abundance so I feel
like I just came from a country that
lives much closer to the peace economy
than we do here and there a country that
hasn't been waging war on other
countries they've been attacked and
they've been threatened what was really
interesting is we went there to try to
get stories about the effects of US
sanctions on the people and it was so
nice to have like a fresh really human
reaction to Trump's sanctions and this
is a country that loves Americans I mean
I've been all over the world this is
kind of baffling how much Iranian love
Americans but they hate Trump and they
feel so messed with because for three
years here's a country that was their
foreign minister said okay we're gonna
do negotiations with the u.s. even
though everybody knows the u.s. is
horrible at negotiations and doesn't
ever get to peace but he did it and
Kerry and he showed up and they came to
a peace accord that everybody was for
and then Trump wins and he rips it up
and you know that all those Iranian
people felt that personally and it's so
nice to be in a country that actually
hasn't been numbed to not feeling when
you're in the midst when you're at the
effects of violence because there's so
much violence in our culture we don't
even recognize it
yeah there are lots of hidden structural
violence --is that are impeding humans
from full self-actualization full peace
activist ation all across the planet
you're hinting at this interesting thing
that is happening around the world which
is where there are little pockets of
peace that are occurring around the
world peace is is flourishing in certain
areas and the war economy can sometimes
come into those areas and cause it to
dismantle that peace for resource
extraction for whatever the recent the
the desire to do a power change there's
a lot of different reasons but Code Pink
does something interesting which you
just started speaking towards which is
you go on these on these these citizen
diplomacy missions and it's cool how
when you go to a place like Iran and
then you start you start actually
surrounding yourself with more and more
we get blessed occasionally we get to
surround ourselves in a place like San
Francisco or in New York these places
are very cosmopolitan already they're
really melting pot so we get to stumble
across people that are from Iran or
South Korea or wherever they may be from
and so we're already getting at least a
little taste but when you go all the way
so the culture you get an even deeper
taste well you get the culture get the
factual culture more so more of it and
so when when you're there it's cool how
when you go on these citizen diplomacy
missions you're you're actually speaking
to political figures there you're
speaking to you're going to museums
you're going into the the cultural
settings you're learning from from the
people there and you're you're making
those dire connections across the planet
that we so need for the peace economy
well I think even more you bring back
the relationships so and you also kind
of break through the mystery walking
from North Korea to South Korea across
the DMZ I can see that almost every trip
that we have taken from code pink people
are like scared about where we're going
they're like super worried about us
because the stories that are fed to us
in our media make us frightened of the
other right it's like oh they're the
boogeyman in some form I remember the
first time before we invaded Iraq we
went to Iraq and people were really
frightened for our lives but Iraq is a
country of beautiful kind generous
loving people and we had an amazing time
but what we were able to bring back is
the truth about what was happening in
Iraq instead of the boogeyman story and
I would say that that's the truth you
know that's what happened with North
Korea to spend a week in North Korea
when literally every media everything is
just like oh my god you're supporting
you know like you can't go because
everybody's gonna throw mud at you but
if you just go with your intention of
connecting with people and bringing back
stories and actually just kind of
breaking through the membrane and then
walking across the DMZ for the first
time in 70 years well you have to
believe that that membrane breaking that
Christine on lead has led to what's
happening as in peace talks and even
though they kind of look like they broke
down that's what peace talks look like
that's what diplomacy looks like it
looks like you sit at a table and kind
of learn what you're gonna need and then
you fight you pivot and you posture I
mean when we were in Iran we met with
Zarif the foreign minister of Iran and
he talked about the difficulty of what's
happening in Iran now and then he'd lost
the confidence of the people that he'd
convinced them that diplomacy would work
but then trumpet ripped up the peace
accord and they're like no we need to
like stand up we need to like not back
down you know this isn't okay and so
he'd lost the confidence of the people
so after our meeting he was on
and it was a big deal and then he gets
invited back and now he has another
level of confidence because people
realize well you can beat up the guy but
then he's the guy really leading you to
what you want because you really don't
want war you really don't want to you
know kick the america back on the teeth
like you're feeling kicked in the teeth
and it was really interesting process to
go through of like we're a peace process
is a long process and it's not easy and
it's why why war happens because it's
super easy in the beginning but like
look how much money we've spent on
Afghanistan or Iraq or Libya you know
it's a crazy amount of money but it's
also the violation of the planet I mean
what it is to the Troops every 22
seconds or something 22 minutes a
another veteran is committing suicide
it's militarize Azhar our culture and
our economy so we don't look at the
costs we just look at that immediate
like oh we're gonna you know bomb our
way we're gonna control our way into
what we want which never happens and so
watching both Korea and Iran are really
beautiful experiences because they are a
possibility of peace war is the you know
no possibility of peace we've gotten
this far because of cooperation and
communication with each other in many
ways and and extending that into the
current geopolitical sphere is
incredibly important and it's paramount
and one of the difficulties that we see
is that we have a billion of us and it's
causing a lot of geopolitical complexity
and when there's this weird thing of
people want democratic elections people
want to see people that are in power for
periods of time actually step down after
they lose an election and in many times
we see them rather than step down we see
them doing things like publicly
executing people that are dissidents of
the
campaigns we see these is so how do you
balance wanting to assist in a country's
democratic process with an authoritarian
dictator rising in that country I I
don't even try because I don't live
there so what I try to do is affect the
country I live inside of which is the
greatest terrorists on the planet and do
we do the most damage and we have the
biggest military budget and we the
imperialism of the US forces violence
around the world I can't begin to have
the hubris that I'm gonna tell another
country what to do when my own country
that I'm a citizen of is already so
violent that's enough for me to deal
with well maybe we don't use the word
tell right but maybe we use the word
assist because try to expose to the
American people what they're doing what
sanctions do to people in Iran what
sanctions do to people in Venezuela with
sanctions do to people in Cuba and Iraq
and you know what are manipulating does
to people in Africa and you know like
how we pretend to give money to Africans
dead deal all this other money how we
claim that other countries are corrupt
when the corruption in America nothing
matches the fact that Apple Amazon
Walmart do not pay taxes a level of
corruption that is allowed and we
pretend like it's legal but it's it it
may be legal but it's violent and its
destructive I mean it's literally money
being siphoned out of the lives of
millions and millions and millions of
workers and not put back into those
communities that's the same thing as
corruption and all these other countries
words I go they're so corrupt and we got
to go in and like save them or whatever
like I'm not into I'm first of all how
do you have democracy on a planet when
there is really just oligarchy
when the power has been given to too few
people it's too much power it's
distorting no human being can like first
of all has ever been trained to have
that much power or you know they just
get thrown into these places they have
egos they have PTSD you know like right
away it it's distorting I would say even
to be a senator in the United States is
distorting so imagine there's no
training like you said there's no
preparation there's pts life experiences
that they've had and the ego rising with
power can begin their show and then the
checks come across the table from
lobbyists and then so with the fact that
we think we live in a democracy I mean
when four trillion dollars are spent on
Elections and you have homeless people
in the streets that's crazy because
you're trying to buy power when we know
the only thing that really changes
things is agitation from the streets
and so we just live in these dreamlike
settings that we pretend everything's
okay
and especially in the u.s. we like we
get to pretend everything okay
while everybody else on the planet is
paying a heavy price and many people in
the United States are paying a heavy
price when when you know just look at
the paradise fire you know how many
people or let the shut down let's just
look at the budget shutdown how many
people live one paycheck away from
homelessness yeah we're not doing it
around 50% can't afford a $500 yeah yeah
pretty scary waiting yeah okay so in the
meantime you know we have people with a
hundred billion dollars but we let that
happen
I mean I don't want to like that's a
form of that's we are effectively
effecting genocide in say Afghanistan
and Iraq when you think of how many
people have been killed its percentage
of a population and we're affecting
slavery but we just legalized them but
our behavior is a behavior we should be
ashamed of but when we don't doesn't get
presented that way it gets presented on
a platter of people being celebrated
because they're billionaires and that's
the cool thing instead of no that is not
cool
rania some thoughts it all it's all
internal but there's nothing that we can
do externally I mean people need to
listen to what you're saying and just
make those adjustments inside people
like violence people like having power
people want to be billionaires people
want to own their own jet airplane and
that's that's a half the problem you
know it's just what we what is among us
is just a reflection of who we are sure
there's lots of beautiful loving people
that understand the problems that are
created with just being ridiculous
however you know they need to pay the
consequences of that and make that
change people are comfortable here in
the United States and that's the problem
not that many are comfortable though
that's the people we need is a very
narrow limb yes it is that very few
people are going to be able to
experience so and when you struggle you
don't have the ability to seek knowledge
yeah and then inform yourself further I
mean I was in in Iraq right after we
invaded and I was in Bremer's he took
over Saddam's palace and I was in his
office which was the office of Saddam so
the whole kind of like the irony of all
of that was not lost on me but his
intelligence officer said keep a dog
hungry and he'll follow you anywhere
when I complained about the chaos they
were creating and clearly what we're
trying to do is create chaos so we have
control and that that's no different
than the war economy it creates a
certain chaos in your life that people
can't get off of the hamster wheel and
that they're on the hamster wheel
because they think they want the jet or
you know whatever but those things
aren't nourishing really Ron also
pointed to the inner peace
being that big thing is that if we can
all figure very imperialistic and
American and inner reflection you know
their places from around the world
prioritize that as their first princess
but you know how that happens it happens
in community yes but we tend to think
it's like mad at I had I'm a I'm very
naive often so one of my naive thoughts
was like well you know at the highest
level and something good what happened
and this is like 25 years ago well we
blew all our populations so let me just
explain what happened
got meditation for everybody in Congress
and 250 of the leadership of you know
many corporations and then what I
realized oh it just they helped them
destroy the world matter well let's
let's let's let's do let's do a little
reset on like a simulation right let's
let's Reese emulator evolution of
humanity right let's say that these are
the things that we like so so let's say
that you go from a from a span of let's
say a hundred million people that are
all the seeds have been watered with
meditation with kindness compassion
sharing abundance across the planet then
the population grows to 200 million and
continues to teach the children that
over time that's how to keep this
abundant that's how to so it's it's like
we're trying to come in and slap the
peace self-work bandaid on top of an
eight billion civilization that has a
too much greed and gluttony to put a
band-aid over there needs to be but I
want to actually ask you this because
you pointed out Jody you said that one
of you said the only way was through the
activism on the streets in terms of the
kind of like this having social change
happened that power react to the people
in the streets is there no way to my
teeth also have like a top-down
influence at the same time as a
bottom-up influence of making change
like putting because I don't think you
know
yeah and why are you looking to why you
looking to be led Alan yes why can't you
evolve where you're at mature human
being where you don't necessarily need
that okay definitely definitely not what
I said let's actually let's take it
let's take what a let's bet let's take
the most instead of straw Manning and
taking the worst possible scenario of
being led been a horrible gluttonous way
let's take a very positive mentality of
it a positive example of it the best
case steel man scenario of where you
have people in both scenarios you know
in a ground state of social activism
working for change as well as in a top
state where you have a lot of greed and
gluttony happening but you have certain
people that are positioned in positions
of power that are slowly starting to e
lose their desire into the others that
are in positions of power about helping
augment this change happening I
personally think that some people like
Marc Benioff is aiming to make a good
amount of change right now you know one
could argue that the Dalai Lama has a
good amount of power and is making good
change right now one could argue that
Elon Musk is doing similar work as well
so you are doing similar work so I don't
necessarily think that having power or
influence is is it makes it from a
top-down position makes it in an able to
affect other people in powerful
positions to help the uprising occur
well we'll just have to agree to
disagree okay you think it's solely from
bottom if it's gonna work it's solely
from bottom up well yes how do you know
the arrogance the works is kind of a
same time yes certainly because that's
the way it works but it works bottom-up
first because to know what's needed has
to come from where need is and what you
have especially in
in the Bay Area
with all its high-tech you know
billionaires is this sense that they
know but they don't know they're about
as disconnected as you can get and in a
way have helped create the situation and
the problems and we want to believe that
it can be easy and I think a lot of the
belief that it can be easy and a lot of
the belief that it's somebody else's job
and the way that we live our lives means
that oh well somebody else is going to
fix that and I don't have to worry about
it has been what causes the situation
where you have a lot of people with
power and no one checking that power and
we being a citizen in democracy is a big
piece of democracy yeah but we're not
we're not informed yeah we don't have
you know any more real media the
foundation we don't have real education
we are not taught to think critically
taught emotional intelligence
we are not taught emotional intelligence
we are lied to from the beginning weird
you know so to believe in these
possibilities you you have to it has to
be a relationship those that have that
are given positions of power need to be
rescissions and responsibility but we
then project power we have we are
accepted and the men who hold high
places must be the ones who start or
women the people yeah it's just the
lyrics of a song and the people who hold
high places you know you very so we we
we wanna everybody it's a it's a form of
laziness it's like their comp we live in
a really complex time and we want
somebody to know the answer because it's
frightening and because we can let our
anxiety be s waged if somebody else is
doing something for a while until that
doesn't work and it you know falls out
in some way that helps us go along our
because if somebody really had to look
starkly into the mechanism it's not
going in a good direction because you
you keep literally raping the needs of
the people for this amassing of money
elsewhere and I mean if you look at it
it's just not gonna work so we're
watching but it's kind of like that you
know slow pop bullying and then all of a
sudden you're dead and so we tend to in
the u.s. think there's an easy answer
think we can control it and think that
somebody else is doing it that there's a
grown-up out there so instead we've
empowered a lot of children with a lot
of power that don't have the capacities
to be responsible for needs and we're
crossing our fingers so the reason we
came up with the kind of idea of like
growing a local peace economy was to
give it a relationship to this war
economy I was like okay here are two
things well
you're not attracted to being part of an
abusive oppressive destructive thing
right that's like not who you want to be
you want to be part of this giving shirt
and it's like vibrant garden of life
because a peace economy is what creates
life so oK we've we've at least opened
it up so you can have a relationship
with it but then the other thing is is
we live in a culture that is the war
economy culture it is those people that
play that game get rewarded and so to
say that the war Ward isn't the learjet
or the billion dollars the reward is my
connection to you
the reward is love the reward is
kindness and caring and rich soil and
beautiful food and singing together and
like all these things that literally do
nourish soul and heart
and and then take away that Hungry Ghost
need for like a Learjet so but that's
practice because your brain has been
told in all these ways that this is the
goal even though you know that very few
people will get there and I think maybe
being a woman makes this easier because
you know all through our childhood the
stories we were told we're about
princesses nice job if you're gonna you
know if you can get it but it's like not
a lot of parentheses out there so early
on we broke from the idea of being a
princess but in the same way we haven't
broke from the idea in this culture of
being a billionaire which is kind of the
same morph it's like oh you know a
hundred people are gonna be it but
there's a billion people in the planet
so what am I gonna be and why do I want
to be a billionaire because that's super
disconnected from everything meaningful
and rich and the soil
but we've been taught that so growing a
local peace economy is about really
getting together and being in community
and learning what that is because we
forgot we forgot that you can be
together and have different points of
view and love each other
we forgot to find out who each other is
really at the depth and core of our
being and fall in love and find out what
we can do together yeah in our local
Pease economy gatherings we go around
the room and we talk about what the
issues are and we find out like we have
a lot of concern but we're not really
engaged in it we can collectivism or
give money but when was the last time we
actually deeply got engaged in it so
I'll tell you a couple stories so in my
community in Venice like okay where's
the local piece that where's the war
economy really affecting people in our
community well guess what there's 1500
this was at the time there's now 2500
there's 1500 homeless kids in our
community ages 15 to 25 so what can we
start to do for them well we started to
feed them out of the trunks of our car
and at the beach and then got a local
Baptist Church to give us a Thursday
where everybody could bring food and
feed them and then they could bring
condoms and backpacks and socks and
jackets and then maybe some people could
come and give them therapy and then the
local clinic could come and give them
medicine and then all of a sudden the
woman one of the women that was
volunteering between the therapy ends up
her husband was the investor and
snapchat he bought the building on the
corner so it's like if you start at the
place of need it built it's like it
builds and enriches and becomes but it's
like it the seed had to start at the
place of need another thing is the
asylum seekers we're all our heart I'm
like watching everybody wringing her
hands oh my god like but what are you
doing and it's like oh I don't know what
to do how do I help well like well let's
see they're gonna be in Tijuana
we live in Los Angeles and so just put
out to the small community this is the
things they say they need my house was
full I had to take a giant truck down of
everything people wanted to give because
people want to give but there's not
those pathways that make it like doable
because people actually have to function
as functionaries to make it happen
so then it's like all these people that
have been around the table come down to
Tijuana and guess what it's hard painful
heartbreaking work but at the end they
were the happiest they've been in a
really really long time
yes we should yes our bodies hurt yes
we've had no sleep yes at you know we
couldn't figure out where you know how
things had to happen we had to figure
out in the moment and solve problems
but in the end the connection to
humanity the stretch of our home like we
forgot what it is to stretch ourselves
beyond what's comfortable and that
that's where life is that's where beauty
is that's where joy is yeah I mean I
could tell you hundred stories like that
yeah
this is why we will need to continue
having these conversations when you come
to the Bay Area because there's so many
good stories to unpack and I think
you're pointing at this really beautiful
aspect of the peace economy which is
first of all there needs to be the peace
economy option the growth of the
perspective of the peace economy across
the world then there's this like you
were indicating this grassroots watering
the seeds of the peace economy across
the pockets of communities around the
world to make that bottom-up social
change
and then you're also indicating from a
from the from the from the cultural
perspective of of just what do we truly
want how what do we want well a lot of
people just want opportunities they just
want an equality of opportunity that
they can pursue whatever they find
actualizes them into the world so how do
we the world
how are you creating it for others yeah
you know it's like there's a lot of what
without like if I want it how am i
creating that for others and I would say
though that's where we lose it
especially in the u.s. we have this very
thing and I think it's trying to say
well if I want that everybody's got to
have that you know so how am I making
that happen
and it's that we people don't get
engaged because because we have a way in
an empire of thinking grandiose notions
and terms just pulling out of like
imperialism is isn't really a very
beautiful thing so I want it unpracticed
I want to decolonize my mind how can I
become in a community of so I I can be
colonize my mind so I even know how to
be a human being I like that you know
really is a human being in the sense of
connecting caring generosity you know
all those aspects of what we want to be
friends with right yeah so I want to
finish the thought quick and then you
know pass it back over to you so there's
this there's a simultaneous effect that
I think is is really crucial about the
war economy to indicate which is it's
just also repurposing of the current
resource flows that we have sight
siphoning away some of the money in
military endeavours and there's really
interesting ways to do things like apply
artificial intelligence to the way that
we manage a lot of the of the spending
that occurs in the military to figure
out how to take ten twenty thirty plus
billion dollars out of the 800 billion
and put it towards education and a bunch
of other fields that that can use its
assistance simultaneously it's about
what we indicated earlier I want to
make sure to touch on this again that if
we are to press this reset simulation
and were able to rethink the way that we
mold give nutrients to the seeds of the
mines that are being born into the world
I think there is a way to get to a peace
economy by passing a war economy
completely on the planet so we did just
rock it up in terms of population and
exponential technology and bopping
people over the head and we had to learn
these lessons in many ways the hard way
or would you say that you're optimistic
in the long run for being able to figure
out how to all play on playground earth
well I don't believe that that's my job
I mean that's all of our jobs and I'm
optimistic because my day is full of
people who are committed to nurturing
and supporting the more beautiful world
that is possible whether that happens is
you know up for grabs it's like how many
people are gonna jump on that and how
many people are gonna go off the cliff I
I don't know I just you know there's the
present and I work on being in
relationship and nurturing and
supporting all those that really are
interested in a more beautiful future
yeah
there's a lot of ways to achieve the
peace economy transition and starting
from this grassroots level of since
yourself work of of helping in my local
communities and then just catalyzing
that unity mindset across the planet is
social crucial simultaneously I want to
address just the sheer you know you've
been going on the citizen diplomacy
mission so you know them you know you
know them right you know right it's
right in your hand plus on you know on
on code pink you can find the links in
the bio you can find all the different
missions that you guys are working on
and when you look at it it's kind of
crazy because what's going on in
Venezuela is kind of crazy what's going
on and we again this is when I was kind
of a crazy
well I'm kind of I'm kind of well when
you look at the Bama when I will you're
well I I hope I hope we I hope we
changed through our efforts okay
capitalism killing socialism it happens
all the time which we've probably the US
has caused taken the lives of 20 million
people who wanted equality there's
something there's something very
important about about providing people
an equality of opportunity to pursue
what they want in the world but then
there's also something strange about
like a forced like equality of putting
like 50% of men into the nursing
position like yes you know what I mean
so so there's like this equality of
opportunity for people to pursue nursing
from around the world but like however
the genders and different people from
around the world end up stacking into
that but is just based on their own
desires in the sense okay but back to
the central principle there are desires
don't get fulfilled anyway and there are
life indicators of that yeah yes that's
the world someone you know like the
Chavistas in Venezuela who have
basically said this is a fight we are
not going to back down on because we
believe that we deserve to have this
life we are not going back to being
slaves to the Machine and the fact that
the u.s. is thinking of putting Elliott
Abrams in charge of Venezuela is a level
of violence my brain actually can't croc
but the support maps show that the
United States and Europe and South
America support the newly-elected the
fascists basically so we're gonna back
the fascist well I do and I know that
we're so proud of well this is the
complication because then show this is
extremely complicated what's going on
whele is just as complicated as what's
happening at the gaza strip is just
complicated you know with our guests
such a pleasure this is you know this is
it it's like we believe these stories
that it's complicated but there's
nothing complicated about the fact that
Israel has its foot on the throat of
Gaza and tries to crush it every day
there is nothing complicated about the
fact that the US has their foot on Cuba
on Venezuela you know like you know in
it caused a coup in Honduras a coup in
Brazil you know like whatever else is
underneath that they committed to like
we're gonna raise the power of the
fascists in Latin America so we can take
on Venezuela anybody that goes against
the US imperialism gets their teeth
kicked in
now none of them are perfect know
anybody who runs a country we already
said that's a pretty you know crazy
you've already gone mad so but do we
think about the people do we think about
what we did in Afghanistan when we
bombed Afghanistan after the Taliban had
said they would take us and give us a
sum up bin Laden well when we first came
to the United States and pushed the
Native Americans using genocide in
slavery it's like it's just another form
of genocide and slavery that's been made
legal but it's still immoral you have
the imperialist perspective that you
have as an extremely important
perspective to help people realize that
that has been happening now across the
world for a very long time as bhopping
people over the head or putting poos in
however you're doing it at the same time
a coup has never worked i I want I want
to say
the COO is gonna work when it is number
worked it is only part of the fashion
there's there's got to be some sort of a
grassroots like we said divine
realization of our fullest collective
unity on the planet okay that's one
thing I don't actually believe in
[Laughter]
collective divine realization I actually
don't believe in that that that like we
all evolved here on earth a hundred
billion humans built the civilization
that we we learned about what it is to
live and we taught each other if you
look at indigenous communities and why
they survived
they taught each other look I've been in
Mauritania it's a country of nomads and
I was there Rosa Mauritania it's the
country between Senegal and Morocco Oh
interesting
yeah it's an amazing country yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah okay so I went out with
one of the Nomad communities and West
African coast my son was like eight and
so I got really connected to this one of
these kids who was eight there are
nomads yeah they all like just don't
have us settled oh right
they're nomads and so I went out with
them and a storm was coming and the
Sheep got sick and another threat was
coming and this eight-year-old knew how
to save the sheep's life how to protect
himself in the wind was coming and who
was who who the the neighboring person
coming and there were I think 97 of
different tribes and he knew all the
markings and all the relationships at
eight and I thought my son's will never
in his entire life know how to take care
of himself like this eight year old when
it became time for you know junior year
abroad I sent them to like a school in
the highest place in the u.s. not abroad
but how to learn how to survive like how
to really learn what leadership was was
that I can take care of my tribe and
that's what he learned because we don't
learn as most indigenous cultures know
how to take care of each other that is a
learned thing that is what a parent does
that's what a tribal leader does that's
the part of responsibility we're not
taking care of each other with because
if we did like my experience in Iran
they know what it is to get to peace if
you're in one Rwanda everyone and we're
not Rwanda knows the seven steps to
genocide when you've been close to that
level of violence there's a hubris and a
narcissism in the u.s. because it hasn't
had to deal with the effects of our own
abuse on the rest of the world but let's
just say a lot of the people in the rest
of the world know what that looks like
and they it's really fascinating it I
think the most fascinating thing in Iran
was to watch how I went to see the
effects of sanctions you know what I
realized as we as human beings are
[ __ ] smart and when people are
controlling us we know how to get around
it right it's the same at the warm you
know the drug war the war I was trying
to end before I could pink
it you know these control systems these
controls they don't work we find ways
around them but they become violent
right if we just let you know if we
didn't have to control which is all
about money and all about greed and all
about like our way and not realizing
what has to happen then it just becomes
ugly and but I'm in Iran watching
everybody get around the sanctions
taking care of each other I didn't see a
homeless person I come back to the
United States I'm in the Tenderloin
crying for 25 minutes
yeah crying yeah these are very very
important stories okay just a quick a
quick thought I mean you guys are doing
your you're aiming for more people to be
aware of what's happening in in Saudi
Arabia as well oh yeah and we've
launched a boycott a boycott so that
here's this here's this idea that the
crown prince of Saudi Arabia we the CIA
says killed jamal Khashoggi the
washington post er
then we see that the treatment of women
the treatment of so many people that are
just sexual etcetera just completely in
slavery it's legal assailants every in
what what's happening to Yemen as well
from Saudi Arabia and the fact that we
didn't care that we had killed a hundred
thousand people in Yemen with our bombs
through Saudi Arabia and so we didn't
care that a ex-cia operative got cut up
into pieces is kind of interesting
correct yes or whatever is happening
with the drones making bombs is less so
in the news that's right yes or what we
do people in Gaza every day yes so so so
here's here's the nuance that I'm so
interested to hear and I mean we're
wrapping here just the thought of with
the thought of that complexity and the
thought of like a Bashar al Assad in
Syria of taking and just killing
dissidents and not wanting to remove
themselves from power this is a complex
thing so when we talk about kind of this
like imperialistic boot of like the US
or let's say China or Russia or whatever
nation it may be at times I'm curious if
the boot didn't come in could there
potentially be a dictator that comes in
and wipes out tens of millions of people
and wants to pursue power anyway that's
a simulation that I just run in my mind
and I'm not quite sure what exactly the
right answers are but I'm so fascinating
with the fact that you pursue for 47
years activism and peace and justice and
you've been doing it with code pink now
for 16 years and I'm just fascinated by
your stories by going to these places in
the world coming back with these stories
about how to inspire community inspire
compassion inspire the peace economy
Judy this is such such a pleasure
quickly quick question on the way out
what is the most beautiful thing in
world well right now you
another human being dedicated to making
the world a more beautiful place
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you very inspirational thank you
I I hope I hope we have more of these
discourses as you come up to the bay
area and join us and we can unpack this
in more detail and we'd love to get
Madea on the show too
yeah we'd love to have when when she's
around you know you come here enough to
to make it happen if she comes yeah yeah
well this you you're up here enough to
make this happen more we'll talk about
that soon thanks everyone for tuning and
we greatly appreciate you tuning and we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on what we talked about
inspire ourselves to have these
conversations and our communities more
more love more compassion more community
social activism get going get loving get
building together get creating we love
you so much thank you thank you for
tuning and check out the links below to
code paint follow Jody on Twitter as
well the links below
thank you around for producing and
directing we love you very much
everyone build the future support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe and support them go build we
love you so much
peace out everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]